so a quiet place starring John Krasinski
Jim from the office and his wife Emily
Blunt is also directed by John Krasinski
it's a directorial debut - and I was
super impressed just starting from the
beginning this movie the opening scene
with the kid with the rocket ship on the
bridge
we all saw in the trailer a hundred
times so it kind of felt like I only
know this was coming here we go but it
still worked amazing and shocked because
the monsters comes in and kills the kid
and then the title of movie comes on the
screen
awesome beginning get you hooked right
away to me and never let go every time I
thought the movies about to slow down it
picks right back up the sound mixing and
the sound ending in this movie in a big
contender at the Oscars this year I'm
calling it it is spectacular because the
way it tells the story here is so
important John Krasinski bernly direct
sound into this I haven't seen sound be
so important in a movie in a long time
to tell a story not just for effect
and particularly the scenes with the
little girl we find that she's deaf you
can hear I was said by the earpiece but
also when it's showing her close-ups you
don't hear anything
really cool he cut between the kid who
can hear and the one that can't really
effective especially all the scenes
would hurt being near the monster
everything was well thought out here and
everything was fresh and a new take on
it a new way to do it every little scene
he really thought out what can switch
things up and not become cliche and this
was mostly a thriller to me I was on the
edge of my seat all the time but
obviously it's also something as a scary
movie the jump scares really worked here
and the reason I thought they were so
effective is like from the original
alien movie where they didn't use his
cheesy horror music like violins
building up and they know something jump
out it was just quiet
so you're just waiting you're like okay
when is this thing gonna pop out and it
just gets you and he did that
brilliantly and Emily Blunt here was
spectacular as the pregnant wife some
incredible acting on her part when her
water breaks she really shows what she
can do as an actress I think her
performance congresista performance is
there I think everything should be
nominated here I'm really really
impressed by this movie I haven't left
the movie in a while being amazed by it
and feeling some
and that really made me leave my
everyday life in my head I completely
forgot about myself or anything I was
worrying about I was fully invest in
this movie and it's been a long time I
didn't look at my phone nothing and
isn't that what this is all about the
ways that the father being the
sacrificial hero at the end was really
good because he was doing it prove how
much he loved his daughter who was
insecure about that and that to me was
really effective it add that heart we
needed it was good they left emily
Blunt's character alive the ending a lot
of people weren't so crazy about I can
see that point but I thought it was
important because it set up for a sequel
well it's an amazing director LaRue for
John Krasinski it makes me excited know
there's another good director in the
game now you need that here in Hollywood
I can't wait to see what else he's got
up his sleeve I'm giving this movie a
nine point five out of ten I think this
is a movie you should see in theaters
because you need that loud sound to come
kicking in from the quiet however if
there's someone talking in your theater
or eating really loud maybe you should
leave and go back to another showing use
movie pass so you don't waste money
because I had a row of teenagers come in
and they were talking the whole movie
and it was really trying to ruin my
experience I had to ignore it so make
sure you see this in a theater with
mature people please comment below you
saw the movie the greed to scrutiny or
respond to everybody I do a bunch of
reviews on movies TV shows I just slowly
interviews as well please subscribe so
you don't miss any of those and keep
coming back
you